- It's kinda like tying
a shoe, I guess, maybe.
(laughs)
I don't know, I don't know
- Please don't tie my hair like a shoe.
- Oh.
- I feel like I should
tease it a little bit first.
- Take three strands
from the top of the head.
- Kinda stressed right now.
(laughing)
- I don't understand your hair.
I've gotta stand up for this or something.
- Yeah, stand up.
- I do the three and then what?
- And then you grab pieces
of hair and then you add them
to each of the three.
- This is hard
Like, I had it good, okay, hold on.
- This is, like, restart number four.
- You sound really confident.
Ow!
- All right, here we go.
Oh, yeah.
We cooking with bacon.
- Did you just give up?
(laughing)
- So okay, I think I'm
ready for the hair tie.
- What are you talking about?
- I'm ready for the hair tie.
- There's a whole clump of--
- I'm ready for the hair tie!
- Do you know how to put
a hair tie on the end?
- Nope.
- Is there even a--
There's no braid.
- (laughing) There's no braid.
- So it's definitely not a French Braid,
and I'm seeing now that there's a part
of my hair that was completely missed.
(clicking camera)
- Oh, my God.
- Okay, Let's start doing this.
- How do ya'll do this?
- Okay, ponytail, now what?
- That's pretty good.
- Oh, God, what?
- The shit hit the fan.
- Don't understand hair.
- Maybe you need some
moisturizer, I don't,
do you want some?
- Excuse me?
- Let's see if you have
a girlfriend at the end
of this video.
- It's all like, split ends.
- Is this going well, still?
- Are you supposed to leave
the hair tie in the middle?
- Fishtail Braid is two pieces.
- Well, I have three in mine.
- So I'm not sure what this is.
- I thought this was just
going to be an easy video.
(laughing)
I was going to come in here
and play with Sophia's hair for a while.
- I'm exhausted.
- No, please don't let that be it.
- We're gonna quit while
we're ahead with this guy.
- It feels like a braid!
- You know, it looks pretty
similar to the last one.
- It feels like you ponytailed it
and just shoved a bobby pin in it.
(laughing)
(clicking camera)
- I'm like, thoroughly defeated right now
(laughing)
- No.
- I'm good.
No, we're doing this.
- Oh, cripes.
- (laughing)
- They do it from the side,
but then it crawls over.
- Uhuh.
- I'm worried that
you're going to break up
with me after that.
- Oh yeah, that feels right.
- Kinda want to throw you a bow and arrow
cause you're looking
like Katniss right now.
- You got rid of it?
Why did you get rid of it?
- I don't know.
- She would loose the Hunger
Games with this hair cut.
- Okay, I think I'm just gonna stop there.
- Okay, do you need a hair tie?
- Ah, if you just keep
your head like that?
(laughing)
- What?
- I messed up this hair tie again.
Why are these things complicated?
- I'm mean that's one,
complete braid, sort of.
- No, I applaud you
because something happened.
- Oh, no, no, no.
What, what happened here?
- Aw, you got all the way around.
- All the way around
- I'm shocked!
- I'm not!
- Good job, babe!
(clicking camera)
- I'm not gonna lie, I was nervous,
and it's so time consuming.
- It was probably one of
the hardest experiences
in my life to be honest.
- You can find a boyfriend who
can French Braid your hair,
marry that guy.
- It's just so sad, what's
happening over there.
- Oh yeah, um hum.
(drumming)
Hmm, you don't know the half of it.